hi everyone today is the day we would
have gathered on old campus to celebrate
our achievements as a class we wish we
could all be together but we hope you've
still been able to enjoy reminisce and
celebrate our class over this past week
we have found many new ways of
celebrating but we've also kept many
traditions one of the traditions we are
excited to be carrying on is the
announcement of our class's Prize
winners although we will be honoring
these recipients when we meet again for
our in-person ceremony please join us
now in congratulating them on their
incredible achievements
[Music]
you
congratulations to all of our winners
and to the entire class of 2020
tomorrow we will officially become
graduates of Yale College when president
salva confers our degrees this is a
particularly noteworthy young as it is a
50th anniversary of co-education at Yale
and 150th anniversary of co-education
at the University as a whole in this
spirit we are delighted to announce our
renowned class day speaker dr. Jean
Bennett one of the first women to
graduate from Yale College dr. Bennett
is a true pioneer in the field of gene
therapy and has dedicated her career to
restoring eyesight as a daughter of a
Yale professor dr. Bennett amassed
herself in the life of the University
long before she became a yearly herself
after graduating from Yale in 1976 with
a Bachelor of Science degree in biology
dr. Bennett under PhD in zoology and
cell and developmental biology from the
University of California Berkeley and
her MD from Harvard she then returned to
New Haven as a postdoctoral researcher
living in silliman College but her
father served as a head of the college
in that the 1980s she completed her
training at Johns Hopkins University who
must know where the accomplishment today
comes from her I work on gene therapy
dr. Bennett created a gene therapy for
Leber congenital amaurosis LCA
which is an aridity disease that causes
only unseen and progressive vision loss
in 2017 the treatment became the
first-ever gene therapy to be approved
by the US Food and Drug Administration
paving the way for other forms and
applications of gene therapy and now as
if M Kirby professor of Ophthalmology at
the University of Pennsylvania dr.
Benton a new team are working on
developing a vaccine the kerbin 19 she
is truly an inspiring example of how
y'all and I continue to make a
difference in the world and so without
further ado please help me welcome dr.
gene Bennett I was told that many of you
would be wearing masks so I tried on a
few of my favorites but none of them
were
right for this or covet 19 so here we go
welcome to the first ever in Yale
college class day at home or wherever
you may be it is such an incredible
honor to welcome you to be one of the
first to congratulate the class of 2020
and your families on this very special
day in this unusual venue I'd like to
give special thanks to president
salivate Dean of Yale College Marvin
Chun writer lecturer and communications
officer Allison Coleman and the class of
2020 students planning this event
Calvin Schwartzberg Ananya Indore Nathan
Isaacs Sarah beech and Michelle hue
thank you for this wonderful opportunity
to share the event with you and
congratulations to the faculty Dean's
and heads of colleges for all the
efforts you've made on behalf of the
students and their families over the
past four years culminating in the
extraordinary events in the past few
months and these last celebratory days
as I was gathering my thoughts together
for this event I told my husband this is
really difficult to put together
especially how the world has changed in
the past few weeks to which my husband a
Princeton graduate replied don't worry
it's just Yale not Princeton five months
ago who could have imagined the events
that have transpired I remember thinking
wow this is the year we'll remember
because of the terrible fires that
consumed exotic animals in Australia who
could have predicted that the entire
world would be faced with the calamity
of even greater proportions that we'd
all be wearing masks hoarding supplies
and being prevented from going to work
or school this 2020 class day experience
demonstrates the adaptiveness of Yale
E's perhaps a virtual class day will
become a new Yale tradition
congratulations new graduates first I
hope that you're all taking good care of
yourselves my heart goes out to those of
you whose friends and families have
suffered the terrible Cobin 19l 'no sand
to all of you have suffered the fallout
from the need for social isolation I
hope that you're all adjusting and
adapting as well as possible if it's in
before the number 2020 now marks and
provides extra meaning to all
Our Lives I enjoy thinking of the order
and beauty and symmetry of numbers the
incidental or coincidental associations
of those numbers and how they impact our
lives our work and the things that give
us pleasure the number 2020 has held
special meeting for me given my career
and experiences reversing blindness the
number brings to mind perfect eyesight
seeing things clearly good acuity
provides us with the platform to see
fine detail to study in to work and
communicate clearly to affirm what is
really important is a shelter in place
we are going to prevent you off from
celebrating your accomplishments and
moving for it with your dreams
hell no Yale class of 2020 will lead the
way to clarity and solutions for the
challenges that we have all been facing
with your resilience energy creativity
and brilliance I hope your experience at
Yale has been fantastic and that you
have had numerous new ventures that
you've gained insights about yourself in
the world and that you've explored new
fields taking on new challenges and made
friends with many many people with
different backgrounds talents hobbies
and experiences one thing for sure is
that the grand finale is unusual if not
memorable your experience has been
marked by a new divide in history before
Corona BC and after Corona AC from a
Yale history perspective this makes the
early college dismissal in April 1775
during the American Revolution seem
trivial although none of these compare
with what we're experiencing now I
witnessed many disruptions while growing
up in New Haven and then attending Yale
during the Vietnam War era in the late
60s there were disruptions on all
campuses in this country due to anti-war
dissent and resistance to the draft in
1970 New Haven was absorbed with
criminal prosecutions against various
members of the Black Panther Party that
had its headquarters on Orchard Street
this case provoked national attention
and tens of thousands of supporters of
the Panthers arrived in New Haven those
were challenging times but I was moved
by the thoughtfulness compassion and
courage of many jelly's in feeding and
housing some of the crowd I know it must
be really difficult imagining what Yale
and you
more like fifty years ago but growing up
here with a father who is a faculty
member and mother who ran one of the
first international baccalaureate
programs in the country was pretty
special my brother Bill sister Nancy and
I hung out on weekends at the Peabody
Museum saw movies at Linsley Chip took
our first swim lessons at the Payne
Whitney gym we did all this unattended
by an adult my first volunteer job in
seventh grade was to feed vampire bats
at climb biology tower with bowls of
blood and that was followed by other
jobs I even got to test intro bio lab
protocols in advance of the incoming
freshmen occasionally I'd serve as a
setup for demonstrations my father gave
on laser physics for one lecture and
Dunham auditorium he asked if anybody
wanted to volunteer to have a wart
removed by his argon laser I raised my
hand another person in the audience did
too fortunately I was selected my father
had a prosthetic arm behind the podium
that was dressed for the same sweater
that I was wearing with me behind the
podium leaning over he proceeded to burn
the prosthetic arm in half with the
laser
although one person yelled get away from
him he's crazy no one came to my rescue
but they all gave me a hand at the end
there were countless other wonderful
experiences one of the most memorable
was participating in the premiere of
Leonard Bernstein's mass with John Moe
cherry and Leonard Bernstein in the
Vienna Opera House that clinched my wish
to go to Yale imagine what Yale was like
when I was an undergrad there were only
four elements fire water earth air well
not quite but there were only occasional
landline rotary phones no cell phones no
911 answering machines webs belong to
spiders I used the slide rule that my
dad had given me for my 16th birthday
for my calculus class there was no email
the cloud was still in the sky we left
messages on message boards or notes
under the door there were no CDs or DVDs
I had a 33 and a third phonograph in a
tape recorder and we used to watch The
Evening News with Walter Cronkite in the
common room on a TV that had a does
channels only three of which had good
reception tweets & Twitter's were only
sounds there were no digital photos we
used cameras with film that we develop
in the darkroom or send a way to be
developed 5gu as part of an apartment
address tender is what we use to light
fires grinder is how we sharpened our
tools applications were documents that
you sent when applying for jobs there
were no emoticons or emojis and
certainly no Google Facebook
tik-tok or snapchat imagine this on the
50th anniversary of co-education
and the hundred and fiftieth anniversary
of women at Yale there were no women
growing up in New Haven I had no idea
that it might even be possible for me to
go to Yale in fact I remember the heated
debates over whether women should be
included the female to male ratio in my
class was about one to ten but in
science ie my major it was closer to one
to fifty for the very few women of color
in my class I'm sure it was an even more
challenging situation it's amazing to me
now that the class of 2020 has slightly
more women than men you likely heard a
lot about what it was like given the
celebration of women at Yale that
occurred last fall and mixers bus loads
of women would arrive from the Seven
Sisters all female colleges like Smith
and Mount Holyoke to be ogled by the men
in my class women athletes in my class
lacked the same kind of facilities and
equipment of the men were given the
experience however introduced me to
situations that I've faced over my
entire professional career where there
are far fewer women than men who've made
it to leadership positions particularly
in the hard sciences it just led me to
proactive in mentoring trainees whether
they be male female or transgender and
it gives me special empathy for the
pressures and intimidation that racial
and ethnic minorities and sometimes now
white men faced today before deciding to
go to Yale I'm worried what would it be
like with my parents being there there
are only a few events that drew
embarrassment for example my brother
Bill who was in the class of 78 in
Berkeley College heard that dad had been
seen swimming with his face
is pushing a bathroom scale through the
pool we weren't quite embarrassed dad
had been collecting data on drag
coefficients in different environments
for his computer class that he was
teaching they'll called him and said dad
I hear you've been weighing yourself in
the Yale pool would you cut it out
despite those minimal challenges I had a
fantastic Yale college experience I took
full advantage of new opportunities many
unique to Yale I got a job washing
glassware in the laboratory of a famous
cell biologist dr. Joseph gall and
ultimately managed to parlay that into a
wonderful independent research
experience that made me decide to go to
graduate school I also learned how to
file with new developments as they're
being made my husband Albert some years
later asked me how I learned to
molecular biology because only the
rudiments existed when I got my start at
Yale I'll ask if I took a Cold Spring
Harbor course very few of the tools for
example restriction enzymes or PCR were
available
I just learned them as if they were
developed and described some of you have
asked why I went to medical school after
graduate school honestly I'm living
proof that you can alter your career
trajectory as circumstances change I
realized that this recombinant DNA tools
were being developed that it might
eventually be possible to treat disease
at its root I had met somebody who was
planning to do this and I decided that's
what I want to do how must you learned
about the diseases amenable to treatment
than to go to medical school on our
first day of medical school the Dean
spoke to us about a terrible disease a
disease that didn't even have a name
that was affecting Haitians and
homosexuals during our clerkships my
fellow students and I were in the
trenches night and day taking care of
dying young men drawing blood gases
doing cultures of every bodily fluid
with barely any protective gear at our
graduation ceremony my classmates a
newlywed husband Albert McGuire was
selected to give the class commencement
speech where he described our experience
learning about this devastating disease
which had recently been given a name
hiv/aids I can't help but think back to
now with the current pandemic in mind of
course current evidence shows that SARS
cough - is far more infectious and more
immediately deadly than HIV but like
SARS co2 we didn't know much about the
biology of HIV we didn't have a
treatment it will take time but
hopefully not too much time to learn
what to do to treat and prevent co19
disease and we're on our way in any case
what Elbert and I learned is that
medical training prepares people to work
at a high level with incredible stress
and endurance and to put the patient
first we've seen this recently starting
in Wuhan then Lamberty in recently New
York City and other cities many of our
medical school classmates including dr.
Nancy Brown the distinguished new Dean
of Yale Medical School and also at Yale
College alumna are leading these battles
another one of the first DL college
co-eds dr. Nancy Berliner is leading the
charge at the dana-farber in Brigham and
Women's Hospital in Boston these leaders
and others and the thousands of doctors
nurses and support staff working day and
night are our heroes if you talk to them
although many are terrified and
exhausted they say they're just doing
their job students ask me how does one
become a gene therapist gene therapy was
still a fantasy when I finished medical
school so I had to develop my own
training plan I was fortunate to
experience the Yale campus again during
my first year of that training plan in
the lab of the Yale Medical School Dean
at the time dr. Leon Rosenberg while my
husband al completed a surgery
internship we had the unique opportunity
to become Cilla manners for that year
while my father was master now known as
head of college this allowed me to meet
many amazing students many of whom have
stayed in touch with my family in
further training at Johns Hopkins we
narrowed in on our target tissue the
retina it was at UPenn where we were
able to turn the fantasy of using genes
to treat disease into a reality of
course to carry out gene therapy you
need to know the genes and how to
deliver them at that point we lacked
both the genes and the tools to deliver
them
efficiently and safely to organs or
animals did that stop us no way
that's where naivete and energy are an
asset what was it like in those early
days we did our first studies in
biohazard gear such as what you commonly
see now in the news in cubicles with
animals with potentially deadly
infectious diseases this is because no
one knew whether the reagents for
testing were safe we D risk them we
figured out how to accomplish the
surgical delivery of gene therapy
reagents to the retina evaluate immune
response and stability of gene transfer
what models would be best and how to
evaluate function and safety of our
newly delivered genes the science was
the easy part
other issues were more challenging such
as trying to get a foothold on the
faculty ladder
the odds were and continue to be
particularly low in the sciences for a
woman at times with the demands and also
the desire to be with my three children
who were then under 6 years of age it
seemed impossible to compete I scoured
my institution for female role models
and I found only two female full
professors numerous other female
scientists have been discouraged from
proceeding and ended up running the labs
of their male colleagues one of the two
female professors who had made it told
me that her idea of a summer vacation
was to leave the lab at 5 p.m. during
the last week of August most other days
she left at 11 p.m. both of them told me
that they decided long ago never to have
children well I had kids so I had to
just try to defy the odds what did I
have to lose we found in our studies
that we can make puppies that had been
born blind see for the very first time
this was through a one-time delivery of
the correct copy of their defective gene
to their blind retinas it was a Eureka
moment to see a puppy curled up in a
corner scared of bumping into something
because it couldn't see and then to see
it running around catching toys and
playing with it sighted friends after a
single treatment we realized the
importance of this finding immediately
as did laymen one of the gene therapy
dogs Lancelot appeared on Good Morning
America
he'd attended
dinner dances of the New York Hilton and
presented his story three different
times to Congress about the importance
of biomedical research he and other
canine participants ended up living to
old age still seeing two of them in our
home he adopted them at the end of the
study of course our thought was wouldn't
it be incredible to make blind children
see we immediately started planning but
had not anticipated that a disaster in
the gene therapy field would bring
everything to a screeching halt the
disaster was the death of the first gene
therapy patient with another disease and
not one of our patients but it was at my
own institution this was damning for the
field of gene therapy the FDA halted all
gene therapy trials and there were
public meetings and scathing letters all
of the funding dried up
gene therapy companies went broke and
investigators abandoned their projects
because of the inhospitable climate for
gene therapy there were now numerous
hurdles in our way the safety
constraints have been ratcheted up so
that there were thirteen different
committees to navigate conflict of
interest Pharmacy device etc and then
even a committee overseeing those
committees before we could even complete
the institutional paperwork we had no
funding but we were fortunate to have an
advocate in dr. Katherine high of the
Children's Hospital of Philadelphia
chop chop realized that the majority of
pediatric onset diseases are genetic in
origin and decided to invest in it we
perfected our religion showed that it
reproducibly and reliably restored
vision and our animal models and was
safe and we addressed one challenge
after another
these included legal issues about
inclusion of children in clinical trials
developing new outcome measures
establishing statistical analysis
protocols for demonstrating efficacy in
this rare disease and addressing all the
unknowns relative to retinal gene
therapy some of these seems strange in
retrospect for example what items should
be included in the informed consent when
blind individuals find it distressing to
be able to see after treatment if so we
could
effort to remove their newly gained
vision something that seemed unthinkable
to the subjects with the gene therapy
reagent have the potential of being
passed on to offspring we and the
parents chuckled as we made sure that
the eight-year-old boys in our study
knew that they would not be allowed to
father children for the next year
there'd only been one gauge of success
the eye chart that doesn't work for the
blind
instead I assembled an obstacle course
with steps turns and doors before
surgery the patient failed after they
navigated perfectly that convinced the
FDA we initiated our human clinical
trial in October 2007 the father of one
appear yell 20/20 classmates Emma Peirce
assisted the volunteers describe
numerous new things that they could see
however we remained cautious until we
had the first objective data in hand
when I first saw the definitive data
after graphing it out late one night I
ran and woke gallop to tell him it was
3:00 a.m. but he didn't mind being woken
for this in the glow of this success my
father asked me whether this work might
benefit the two blind students he had
known in Suliman I told him dad
the chances are really slim because this
gene defect is rare it probably wouldn't
help them a few months later my father
died and then shortly after his death I
received a message that the blindness of
those two individuals was due to the
very gene defect that we were studying
although when we started we just wanted
to see if this would work we realized
that once it did work we had to follow
it to the very end drug approval so that
others could benefit of course we had
not received any training in this
process nor was there a path however we
persevered with every obstacle thrown
our way it was an emotional moment when
we received unanimous approval by the
FDA for the drug Lux turn into summer
2017 and then worldwide the following
year we were truly the fortunate ones to
be able to witness the dramatic life
changes experienced by these courageous
pioneers being able to put aside their
Braille books and blind cane
go to school get a job see their
children's faces for the first time live
independently ski hike you name it we
were so lucky to be in the situation to
know these people and to witness such
improvements in their vision and lives
my husband routinely treats people with
this inherited blindness now with his
first approved gene therapy we never
tire of hearing their stories of what
they can do now that they can see well
and we've been working to develop the
next generation of gene therapies with
the current coronavirus situation I like
scientists here at Yale and all over the
world have had to shut down my lab as
only research relevant to cope in 19 has
been declared essential this is where
some of my Yale experience and grit and
determination kicked in after a few days
of anxiety shock and depression I began
reading what is known about the
molecular biology virology immunology
and pathology of SARS co2 I started
talking to one of the lead collaborators
who himself is a Yale College graduate
and who I learned recently has a
daughter Sarah in this class
congratulations havens we discussed how
to apply and pivot our expertise and
resources to start working on this it
didn't take long for us to establish the
preliminary set of studies aiming to
develop a safe and effective vaccine we
have no guarantee if we'll be successful
but if we don't try we won't have
anything this effort has energized me
and I'm sure this resonates with you we
do not want to have a future
overshadowed by coronavirus I know that
at some point we will be able to get
back to the projects we put on hold in
the meantime each of us can try to
figure out how to apply our skills the
best or to do what we can to contribute
I truly believe that my Yale education
prepared me to reconfigure when
appropriate and take on challenges as
they appear to have the bold hopes
perseverance determination thick skin
and patience to see projects through
some members of your class have asked me
whether they'll ever see their friends
from the elegant graduates not a problem
I've stayed in touch with faculty
members and friends from numerous
Ciel experiences from the dining hall
roommates classes the Elle symphony from
attending performances and museums and
athletic events I rekindled connections
at reunions my undergraduate friends and
I have shared life events weddings
births of children promotions shows
concerts career changes sad events
they're like extended family in fact
some of the first friends I contact when
the pandemic hit or my Yale
undergraduate friends those
relationships are enduring and
ever-expanding
we are all now faced with an opportunity
for reflection the world has been so
divided but for once our stress is the
same stress something that binds us
together our views of safety have
changed instead of being scared of
others we worry about being the
unwitting mules of harm being Mary
Mallon aka typhoid mary the cook who
silently spread typhoid fever to more
than 50 people in the early 1900s
conversely those of us who have been
healthy don't want to experience the
disease we or at least most of us have
been following guidelines for social
distancing and protective steps who
would have thought that seeing everyone
wearing masks would be the new norm now
when I see images of groups of people
without masks I wonder where are those
people that they're not concerned it is
heartening to see this solidarity
concern and respect some of the changes
I've noticed in recent weeks are truly
beautiful it seems to me that people
have become more outgoing and more
caring they're bringing groceries and
medicines to those in need
lending a helping hand even if there are
some kooky elements like stop
stockpiling toilet paper I've had the
opportunity to meet neighbors we never
even knew existed while walking my dogs
people call out from across the street
to ask how the family is doing people
are more appreciative and thankful we
see images and videos of groups
cheering and clapping for people who've
saved lives instead of going out to
restaurants people are cooking in
new recipes despite worries about
gaining the covin 20 children have time
to be kids instead of rushing from event
to event they are riding their bikes
around the neighborhood without
helicopter parents part of the reason is
likely that there's no traffic and it's
much safer for them Plus maybe their
parents don't mind having a few minutes
of peace and quiet
it is nice to be able to take advantage
of new technologies to meet instead of
flying everywhere the sky is even bluer
for it and our world has less machine
made noise I hear reports of dolphins
swimming in the canals of Venice and I'm
skeptical of them until I step outside
my home and I see a fox running across
my neighbor's yard and a deer with her
fawn walking slowly down the middle of
the street the IT world has proven over
and over again and right now in fact
shout-out to Rick Lyon and Douglas
Forbush that they can keep us all
connected whether it be in classes
performances art exhibits lectures
births or class day it's strange and
confusing and funny and surreal and
endearing and heartening giving us all a
feeling of connection we now have the
demonstrated opportunities for carrying
out virtual education telemedicine
thesis defenses and for sharing artwork
we can take virtual tours of no trend on
we can intend the live stream
performances of symphonies attendance
has never been higher we see Lady gaga
Mick Jagger Taylor Swift and other stars
performing in their basements and were
entertained by comedians appearing in
their kitchens on Saturday Night Live
there's baseball in ballparks without
fans online support groups dance classes
weight lifting body combat improvisation
memes and I even saw poker games on the
L Facebook page the coronavirus cruelly
robbed you of those very last days at
Yale this is a huge deal and certainly
nothing that any of us anticipated
however do not despair this terrible
experience has created new opportunities
and your class will shape things to come
this event will galvanize you all to put
your talents expertise imagine a
passions to good use you have a huge
opportunity for a recent to re-engineer
our world disaster makes the impossible
become possible the pandemic has shown
us how quickly things can change if they
must we are still in shock adjusting
grieving warning and recalibrating but
class of 2020 soon we will need you all
the step in and roll up your sleeves the
way one deals with obstacles is often
what sets apart those that accomplish
their goals and those who don't of
course a little luck helps that if we
don't try we don't succeed although it
can be frustrating we all learn from the
challenges that are placed in our path
and the mistakes we make along the way
we learned from being tested and going
through disruptions we learn how to be
independent as well as how to
collaborate and work with others it's
okay to worry a little bit
that's a protective mechanism as long as
it's in check but be assured that this
long and winding road will lead us to
opportunities and solutions it may take
time for each of you to recognize where
you best fit in but there are numerous
opportunities AC after Corona for the
short term you can take advantage of
having the time and physical isolation
to read and think and to fill in the
gaps in your knowledge base it's also
important to spend the time on yourself
to develop your talents whether they be
to write draw sing dance we won't have
this opportunity forever many of you are
nurturing encouraging and inspiring your
friends siblings parents and
grandparents what a great opportunity to
strengthen those unique relationships
those who have suffered terrible kovat
19 symptoms are going to need extra
physical and psychological support from
all of us to get well and independent
again people are going to say we will
get through this that is not enough we
need to think about the long term for
those of you who carry out scientific
research do not fear the majority of you
who have worked in research labs have
had to curtail those relationships due
to coronavirus we need to get ready
things will crank up sooner than you
think for those in other fields there
will be numerous opportunities we depend
you to unite our fragmented government
to use your economic and financial
acumen to address financial problems to
foster business opportunities that are
honest and not self-serving
to treat our workers properly keep them
out of harm's way and give them a
liveable minimum wage daycare and sick
leave to take care of our precious earth
and provide habitats for our creatures
and birds to take care of the homeless
impoverished the mentally ill and those
who are addicted to narcotics to provide
everyone with a high-quality education
we need to stand up to bullies and to
make sure that there's no interference
from foreign governments and our
elections remember to vote and we need
to support all of those people who bring
beauty joy and meaning to our lives
every day through music art literature
comedy and performance
move over scattered boastful incoherent
and unscientific behavior and make way
for compassion and what Camus described
in the plague as being the most
important decency above all there is
hope we have all learned and reflected
on what is really important our
relationships with one another we can
all draw inspiration from those who have
surmounted enormous obstacles to arrive
at our new normal and make that even
better more just and more secure than
the old normal you're such an
extraordinarily resilient and diverse
and brave class class of 2020 you're
wired pragmatic driven empathetic and
creative you have shown through the
recent events how we are connected and
that there come extraordinary times when
we're impelled to take care of one
another in a basic and profound way the
pandemic has already taught you to think
beyond your own past expectations to
reformulate them and begin the process
of becoming the next generation of
leaders I applaud each and every one of
you my heartiest congratulations and my
very best wishes for your continued good
health happiness and connectedness
Thank You dr. Bennett for your inspiring
words your message is especially
powerful in the current situation in
fact it's at times like these when we
appreciate even more those figures who
have been so instrumental in our daily
lives on campus and have really helped
to make you feel like home over the past
couple of years being away from campus
now it just makes us remember how much
we value their love and support at the
same time we also are immensely grateful
to those who have been so key to making
this virtual graduation ceremony
possible they've put in countless hours
to try to make our ceremony as special
as it possibly can be given the
circumstances and we are so so grateful
and finally to all of our families and
loved ones who have helped us and
supported us all the way to this
important milestone thank you so much we
truly could not be here without you and
this is a celebration of you as well
thank you so much and to everyone family
and friends watching from home thank you
for joining us this week we're excited
to continue celebrating when we come
together in the future
until then we hope that you and your
loved ones stay safe and healthy to
conclude our class day celebrations we
ask that you'll join us in singing the
Yale University alma mater Brite college
years we encourage you to take out the
handkerchief you received in the class
date box or the one you might still have
from our first week at Yale we now
present you Brite college years led by
the senior members of the Yale glee club
as directed by Jeffrey Duma and the
members of the Yale bands as directed by
Thomas Duffy thank you all and we're
glad to have celebrated these bright
college years with each and every one of
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]